يريد مارك زوكربيرج منك
أن تنفق أموالًا حقيقية على
المصممين الراقيين ، حسنًا ،
لا تتقن الفستان أنت بل الصورة الرمزية الخاصة بك
ولتبيع الفكرة ، أظهر هو ونائبه للأزياء
صورته الرمزية مزينة في
كل شيء من موتوكروس بالنسياغا إلى
مجموعة شورت برادا أنا  أعتقد أن هذا
يبدو رائعًا لبدلة توم براون القصيرة
ذات الخطوط إذا كنت أرتدي بدلة
أعتقد أنها تبدو جميلة جدًا ، فهذا أمر
كبير إذا لاحظ شخص ما ملابس رقمية
من رجل يرتدي زيًا واحدًا ،
تحقق من خزانة zuck الفعلية مع
قمصان متطابقة و  هوديس ، هل يمكنك أن
تتخيله في هذا النوع الكلاسيكي من
نوع من الأناقة مثل تلميذ اللغة الإنجليزية أو
يرتدي بنطال جينز منخفض الارتفاع في ليلة في الخارج ،
ربما ليلة جيدة من برمجة الكمبيوتر ،
كان يُطلق على صورته الرمزية الحديثة اسم zuckertar ، حيث
قام أحد النقاد بإنفاق المال لوضع
الملابس على ملابسك.  الصورة الرمزية في هذا الاقتصاد ،
بغض النظر عن مدى
استهجان زوكربيرج لذاته ،
فأنا أعني أن السؤال الوحيد هو هل أنا
رائع بما يكفي لارتداء
ذلك التويتر ، دعه يحصل على هذا الأمر.
قم باللباس مع الصورة الرمزية الخاصة بك
لتذكيرك ببعض
الصور الرمزية للأيام الخوالي كدمى رقمية ،
لكن مهلا على الأقل ارتداء الصورة الرمزية الخاصة بك في
الملابس الفاشلة المصممة أرخص بكثير من
تلبيس نفسك الحقيقية
، ستتراوح الملابس الراقية من
2.99
إلى 8.99
ولكن مع ملابسه  الحديث عن ارتداء قماش تيري
زوك فجر أوراق اعتماده في عالم الموضة ، هل
أنا أجعلك تبكي من الداخل
والخارج ، إنه رجل هبط على
عدة قوائم من أسوأ الملابس ولكن ربما
ستدرج نفسه الافتراضية في قائمة أفضل الشخصيات الرمزية في الأناقة.  أنا بارد بما يكفي
لارتداء تلك نيويورك